when my plane landed here the flight
attendant welcomed everyone to West
Yellowstone Montana and added don't feed
the Bears there's a lot of reminders not
to do that the whole of Yellowstone Park
which starts just a couple hundred
meters that way is Bear Country and
hikers and campers heading from this
town to the Wilderness will bring food
with them if the wind's in the right
direction then a bear can smell that
food miles away which isn't great for
the humans who do not want a hungry
grizzly bear that weighs a third of a
ton rummaging through and destroying
their campsite but it's not great for
the Bears either bears are relatively
smart creatures and if one of them makes
the connection between humans and easily
available food it might start seeking
out campsites and homes it might get
aggressive and in that case it might
have to be euthanized killed not just
for human safety but because it might
pass that behavior along to its Cubs and
along to their cubs and suddenly the
Wilderness isn't so wild anymore so
that's problem number one there are
rules for people going into the park and
one of them involves keeping all your
food in Bear resist containers a bit
like these trash cans
so problem number two how do you certify
that a container is actually Bear
resistant here at the grizzly and wolf
Discovery Center they're trying to solve
both those problems in one go rather
than euthanizing a bear that's a bit too
interested in picnic baskets it can get
moved here just outside the park where
it might get a new job testing
containers on average our Bears test
around 60 products per season which runs
from April 1st to October 1st without a
doubt coolers are number one 30 to 40
coolers seems like everybody wants to
make a bear resistant cooler these days
so then we have the trash cans something
you roll out to the end of your driveway
there's some Metal Products even get
tested here we want those products to
pass the test so that out in the field a
bear doesn't get that food reward and
moves on continues back into the woods
where they belong fish is their number
one favorite peanut butter and honey is
a close second and then we either put
dry dog kibble or or dog treat it's
inside quite often we put a dummy
container in to to give those Bears a
food reward every once in a while if
they were to not be able to get into a
product 20 products in a row why perhaps
would they try to get in that 21st time
so let them remember that there's a lot
of goodies inside and they need to put
that effort into trying to get in
definitely no bears in here right now no
bears
lots of uh double checks security you
know radio calls so obviously I asked
for the camera inside one of the dummy
trash cans one of the trash cans that
the Bears would definitely get into I
didn't think the team here would let me
but they said yes immediately and in
hindsight of course they said yes the
Bears are literally being given a load
of plastic and metal to rip apart in the
hope of reaching the food inside a
camera in a protective case is not going
to make any difference to them they're
not going to eat it they're smart enough
not to the Bear's favorite method at
least with the trash can we find is the
CPR method pushing up and down with
their paws and a lot of times they
separate the lid from the body with
coolers they're going to use their teeth
to tear the plastic part and then then
the styrofoam and then the next layer
and then it's a cleanup on aisle four my
big concern here was Animal Welfare
there is a centuries-long history of
bears being mistreated for entertainment
and I do not want to be part of that
this place has to survive as a
non-profit and as a tourist attraction
but that can't mean putting the Bear's
wealth out at risk fortunately the team
here are very clear that they don't want
that to happen either we would never
want to put the Bears at risk for sure
these are all rescued bears that came
from the wild we're very very hands-off
we don't call out to the Bears we don't
talk to the Bears we want them to remain
as wild as possible we also ask the
public to not call out to the Bears the
bear habitat is about an acre in size we
do have two ponds a waterfall and lots
of trees and rocks and logs we stalked
the pond with fish All Summer Long the
food that's hidden out into the the bear
habitat in front of the public is just a
an enrichment to keep them active to
snack let them do their natural
behaviors like they would in the wild it
turns out that it's really difficult to
make it container that humans will want
to use and can use but Bears can't get
into yesterday I tried to use one of
those bear resistant trash cans and it's
been jammed Shut by someone that
apparently couldn't figure it out and
just shove their garbage in the latch
because there's an old quote allegedly
from some park ranger in the 1980s I
couldn't find the original source that
says there's a considerable overlap
between the brain power of the most
intelligent bears and the least
intelligent tourists 60 Minutes of
contact Time quarter inch hole or larger
is a fail we always say Bearer resistant
because we feel that if you give a bear
an unlimited amount of time they'll get
in most everything not bear proof no
guarantees those bears are going to come
around and try to get that easy meal
each and every time we're trying to
educate the visitors to not make the
same mistakes that got most of our Bears
here in the first place more and more
bears are staying out of trouble in the
wild
I sadly definitely not recording anymore
oh don't put it in the water don't do
not put the GoPro in the water there
that's
it it's gone that's not ideal